[Music]
david is in tucson arizona hi david how
are you
hello david dr john i appreciate your
taking my call
our pleasure i don't know if you've
noticed but some of your principles
differ a little bit from conventional
advice
stop it
crazy i love it
my questions are about investment mix
yeah you talk about growth aggressive
growth
uh growth and income and international
and some of those aren't the
terms many others use so i was hoping
you could characterize those a little
for me but
the big question is it's all stock
nothing else mixed with it how does that
change
related to age and goals and
particularly as you're starting to get
closer to retirement
yeah really really good question and uh
you're right none of those things line
up with
conventional uh wisdom it does
mostly it's about a 90 overlap but
there's enough uh nuanced
uh that i don't agree with with
traditional financial planning theory
that they all stay pissed off at me all
the time um
and right write nasty blogs and stuff
but anyway so let's go back to the first
question
uh an aggressive growth fund is also
called a small
cap cap means capitalization
in the financial world so a small
company
small company fund okay and that's your
your startup companies
uh your tech companies volatile uh
wild that's the aggressive growth stock
mutual fund okay
sometimes they call it an emerging
market fund
too okay so that's the aggressive the
international
obviously means overseas stocks or
foreign stocks
and sometimes you'll see it called that
it has a kissing cousin called a
uh a global fund and so if you think
about the whole globe
like he's got the whole world and his so
it's the globe
okay the whole globe right and so that
means it's got u.s stocks in it too
it's not just overseas or not just
international
pure international has no u.s in it no
american companies in it
um and so the global funds typically
outperform the international funds
because american stocks typically
outperform the rest of the world
by and large as a whole okay now then a
a
a growth fund is also called uh you know
it's just a middle of the road
an index fund uh an s p 500 fund would
qualify as a growth fund
uh but it's just a company that it's a
it's a mutual fund that has stocks in it
that are growing so it's kind of
mid-range
uh mid-cap fund it's also called uh
the uh the growth and income will have a
few bonds in it a lot of times
uh but it's mainly huge companies so
sometimes called a blue chip
fund and or a large
cap fund the other end of the spectrum
from the small cap
so this is uh alcoa aluminum
general motors boring
most of the time compared to a little
startup company on the other end of the
spectrum that's going zoom zoom or not
and back and forth and very volatile and
all over the map so
that's the mix that we recommend then uh
and that's that's a question that's
the an answer that's great for the whole
audience to hear that's why i'm taking a
little extra time with it
then the uh the the second thing part of
your question is the the allocation
theory which is that as you get older
you should move from
equities or stock type mutual funds
towards
bonds and money markets to get safer and
safer as you move towards retirement and
that's the theory of financial planning
i don't agree with
and i'll give you my basis for my
disagreement okay
it's called common sense so here's the
thing
so if you get to retirement and you have
half a million million and a half in
your 401k something like that
even 300 000 you're likely at 65
never going to touch the principal
you're going to only live off of the
income that it creates
you know unless you just want to drain
the account down now if you want to
drain the account down then you can
change your
allocations based on the fact that
you're going to use the money
but if you are 65 years old at
retirement and you are healthy
statistically the average death age of a
male in america
is 74 of a female is 76 right now
however if you make it to 65 and you're
healthy statistically you're going to
make it to 90.
so you have 25 freaking years
in order to outpace inflation and so if
you follow these
stupid allocation theory and you move
all your money into underperforming
items that are say
quote-unquote safer then you're going to
make no money for 25 years and
inflation's going to kick your butt
and so i'm 60 and i'm 100
invested in the four types i talked
about as far as the stock market goes
i don't have any bonds other than if
they sum in my growth and income
funds there might be some bonds in that
but i don't i don't i don't buy bonds i
don't have
i'm not moving towards stocks because
i'm decrepit and old at 60 years old
no i got 30 freaking years it's like
talking to a 30 year old and saying
oh be conservative because you're going
to be 60. it's the same 30 years
from 30 to 60 as it is from 60 to 90.
the only difference is is that everybody
freaks out and says oh my god you're old
so you have to get really super safe now
drop all of your performance down to
nothing and let inflation be higher than
the performance of your portfolio
and kick your butt it's absolutely
asinine it's an asinine theory
but the financial planning communities
block a bunch of lemmings
sometimes they just follow each other
off the cliff whatever one of them says
do they all go do
and no one stops to question that the
emperor has no clothes except me
and then of course i have blogs written
because i said the emperor is butt naked
so uh it's a bad idea it's a bad idea
now if you've got money that you want to
access
and you're going to tear the principal
down in the next five years then yes
get more conservative and move out of
equities but if you're going to live off
of the goose
you want to keep that goose good and fat
and let it keep growing and outpacing
inflation
and that is what i'm doing
uh which um you know and that's more
than many
financial advisors can say yeah yeah i
can't tell you how many
financial advisors dave i've sat with
and they said i want you to give me the
exact portfolio breakdown that you have
for your family
and the response is almost universally
well you know see
what we're doing here is this uh nope
whatever you're doing with your family
is what i want to do in my house yeah i
don't i've never
told somebody to do something in 30
years of doing this that i don't do
yeah i never asked somebody live debt
free and then i was borrowing money
i don't have a super secret double
backflip family partnership
limited thing to
it's a trick that the secrets of the
rich that nobody knows about
nope just got real estate no debt
that's boring money and mutual funds
just zero sex appeal
pretty comfortable with that
[Laughter]
pretty comfortable with that yeah that's
that's that's the new t-shirt dave
ramsey
zero sex appeal and i'm good with that
yeah 700
several hundred million dollars i'm with
them all good pretty good with that